hey what's up guys it's beautiful and
this master Oh everybody more we got
some new members here I know you I know
I know what you're thinking oh he's gone
crazy
huh I have real friends in real life
okay these are these are just we got a
trouble
krumping back mr. president thank you
for joining us today thank you thank you
we also have Bonnie
Jenny here dating y'all think I'm out of
ideas
hahaha no give me an idea
Danny you made an idea right now why
don't you check out some subreddits
PewDiePie all right subreddit we're
gonna go through subreddit that's fun
hey not bad Danny does anyone know like
a weird subreddit like I'm not good idea
where you gotta be a team to check this
one I was why is it so sexual yeah ah no
no guy what is wrong with don't like
that don't look all right does anyone
else have any better idea the night I'll
take anything I'm desperate burdens
[ __ ] food what say that again rule
rule would impose what kind of what kind
of [ __ ] are you into markiplier okay try
that's the reddit that's a that's a
subreddit okay can't be that bad I want
to just cry I don't why would you do
that to a dragon I used to love dragons
mark your ass
Saruman you're a pleasure go into the
ceiling I don't you're going to the
ceiling with the rest of them okay you
can come back when you don't suggest
this god-awful [ __ ] does anyone else
have any better ideas then dragon
[ __ ] car jack dude deep I made you
should look at the collage subreddit
okay
Kellogg's gone wild even better Kay
let's check Kellogg's gone wild out how
does it get so big how does it get so
big how does an [ __ ] get that big
does anyone have a better idea
haha oblong Emma what do you got off
your own penis no I'm not going to check
out your channel Emma come please I beg
you just one more suggestion guilty
pleasures guilty pleasure what could
that be
a subreddit dedicated to guilty
pleasures of music what's your guilty
pleasure fun
[Music]
it's lit I'm not judging I'm not judging
that's cool you know whatever you're
into illusion porn oh that's interesting
that's definitely interesting three what
the [ __ ]
what is it happening it looks so
beautiful
oh my god what the [ __ ] happened here
it's a log dog how is no one impressed
the log dog oh yeah so what do you do
for a living well you know I create
kitties how to blanket with shadows all
right I need more suggestions can
someone please help out for one can you
help out I'm dying here literally give
me anything yes a claw oh that's cool oh
yeah I've seen this one
you punches the kangaroo it's [ __ ]
amazing what are you doing Wow
ha ha ha ha ha ha how how the [ __ ] did
you do that that's some amazing editing
I wish I had that ability just spawned
Conor McGregor at any time you see we're
so cute you know that so cute I ship
them I ship them come on guys come on
need some good [ __ ] for once come up
good come on - let it out with the back
who said it who was it who said birds
with penises forget it I'm not leaving
until sleepy did you say birds with
human penises yes I did I like me some
dicks on chicks what kind of weird [ __ ]
are you into buddy alright let's check
it out together sleepy like the good old
days don't [ __ ] on me please why why
what the [ __ ] man what the [ __ ] I got a
check on the good stuff got it alright
you're just [ __ ] weird
this is all your fault ok it's not my
fault
this channel is failing ok it's your
now we're not you Danny I'm talking to
Danny okay come on man stop I need
something interesting the Ainsley
Harriott
subreddit so Ainsley from the 90s damn
he looks so cool so cute
this is when he bribed sister I miss him
so much anguish I missed your smile I
miss your master
I miss your weight let's go just go
[Music]
is it like you enjoy watching this video
check out another one over here and the
rumor truly would like to have your left
alight please leave a like